bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau journal sur tv fil 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et en
ce mercredi 8 avril il sera notamment
question de ce retour aux urnes pour les
visites noise et lévis sinois il faudra
dimanche désigner le nouveau maire de la
commune iv listes se présentent elles
sont actuellement sur le terrain à
maurepas le centre nautique fermé pour
raisons de sécurité que va-t-il se
passer début mais une fois le nouveau
rapport d'expertisé connu réponse avec
grégory gary astier maire ump de la
ville est invitée du journal le réseau
de trains de banlieue de la sncf entend
se moderniser et enfin retrouver
l'adhésion de l'ensemble de ses usagers
présentation ce matin à paris les
projets pour 2015 et des résultats des
premières actions menées est depuis ces
dernières années
après six mois de fermeture suite à un
incendie l'accueil de jour du secours
catholique de versailles a rouvert ses
portes le 9 mars dernier le centre
accueille en moyenne une cinquantaine de
personnes par jour il a été réaménagé
pour l'occasion 130000 euros de travaux
nécessaires aujourd'hui plus de place
pour un accueil plus convivial et des
activités collectives qui se succèdent
animé par les 50 bénévoles qui se
relaient chaque jour
alors le centre il a différents lieux il
a d'abord un lieu global de convivialité
dans lequel on peut échanger se
rencontrer des jeunes et il ya des
bureaux plus petits pour des entretiens
en particulier pour véritablement
rentrer sur la problématique d'une
personne en particulier il ya tout un
volet sanitaire avec des douches des
machines à laver sèche-linge
de la personne peut venir laver son
linge
récupérer du linge propre et sec en bon
état personnes qui sont sans domicile la
première chose qu'elle recherche bien
sûr c'est souvent à une aide alimentaire
et autres
la première chose qu'elle recherche
c'est surtout un lieu où on puisse les
accueillir les écouter ou et puis parler
et être entendu donc ça ce lieu
correspond à ça et c'est vraiment
important pour elle propos recueillis
par william el est de son côté le
secours populaire des yvelines recherche
des familles pour les vacances cet été
si vous avez la possibilité d'accueillir
des jeunes de 6 à 11 ans pour des
séjours de quinze jours ou de trois
semaines au mois de juillet au mois
d'août soit à votre domicile soit sur
votre lieu de vacances rendez vous sur
le site internet du secours populaire
paris l'île de france et le nord du pays
connaissent aujourd'hui un nouveau pic
de pollution l'air que nous respirons
sur l'ensemble de l'ile-de-france et
analyser tous les jours par airparif
association agréée par le ministère de
l'environnement en complémentarité sur
le plateau de saclay le laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
évalue aussi la pollution qui peut avoir
plusieurs origines explications de deux
chercheurs du laboratoire le carbone
c'est typiquement pour avoir une image
un peu précis c'est typiquement eux
les particules noires qu'on peut
observer quand on fait soit un barbecue
soit
un feu de cheminée soit
les émissions que l'on peut le voir les
particules que l'on voit qu'ils sortent
d'un pot d'échappement nos zones il est
pas produit directement dans
l'atmosphère
il faut décomposer qu'on appelle
précurseur donc les oxydes d azote qui
sont émis par le trafic et les composés
organiques volatils et c'est ce mélange
là qui va former nos zones et l'ozone
on respire dans nos villes et surtout
autour de nos villes il est toxique pour
la santé transports la sncf a présenté
ce matin ses projets pour l'année 2015
concernant le transilien ces projets
concerneront notamment dans les yvelines
les lignes c est les u qui desservent
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
des aménagements sont prévus d'ici de la
la fin de l'année pour permettre de
diminuer la saturation des rames et
surtout remédier à l'ancienneté des
infrastructures mélanie poker yolaine
thorez et william l retards à répétition
ram saturé infrastructures obsolètes
le transilien yvelinois est dans la
ligne de mire des usagers conscient des
difficultés transilien sncf a engagé des
études et discussions pour analyser ces
difficultés notamment sur la ligne aile
avec le tronçons paris versailles
il ya deux problèmes aujourd'hui un la
ligne est saturé c'est à dire que alors
qu'elle fonctionnait très bien il ya
quelques années fait qui est de plus en
plus de voyageurs fait que les temps
d'attentes hangar montée décembre sont
de plus en plus en plus important et
donc un effet boule de neige les trains
prennent depuis
dorota en collaboration avec
l'association plus de train pour la
défense transilien à élaborer un nouveau
plan de transport comprenant une
meilleure répartition des trains il sera
mis en oeuvre le 13 décembre de cette
année autre sujet d'amélioration la
ligne du rer c pour laquelle plus d'un
milliard d'euros de travaux sont engagés
jusqu'en 2020 cette ligne souffre
particulièrement de l'ancienneté de ses
infrastructures
la ligne c est là une offre associant
extrêmement ancienne elle à une
caténaire qui a plus de 95 ans et donc
il faut la rénover il faut rénover
également les rails dans le tronçon
central
et ce sont les travaux qu'on engage à
partir de 2015
dernière annonce qui concerne aussi les
yvelinois le forfait tout voté en
décembre 2014 avec un tarif unique 2 70
euros
il entrera en vigueur le 1er septembre
prochain
politique debout la france prépare les
régionales de décembre prochain son chef
de file nicolas dupont aignan annonce
être candidat tête de liste en
ile-de-france et le 11 avril que
l'information sera officialisée lors
d'un conseil national 11 avril date
également du lancement de campagne sur
ce même secteur de valérie pécresse pour
l'ump les électeurs vis sinois sont eux
appelés aux yeux en est dès ce week end
pour le premier tour de l'élection
municipale partielle 4 litres seront
proposées dimanche trois listes de
droite une liste de gauche
le détail des candidats a rencontré à
lors de la traditionnelle distribution
de tracts 4 nuls à taux et le diwan plus
d'une semaine après les départementales
il faut repartir en campagne
alexandre arrosée qui tout juste élue
conseillère du canton reprend son bâton
de pèlerin cette fois pour la mairie une
mairie que l'ancienne première adjointe
avait conquis en mars 2014
devançant de 15 mois alexis piette de
recours plus tard le conseil d'état a
tranché il faut aller revoter toujours
aussi motivée et prête à reprendre le
travail comme on va voir l'avenir de
notre ville comment l'aménager pour que
ça reste une une petite ville agréable
pour préserver l'art de vivre à voisins
tout en a froid répondre à nos
obligations qui aussi au besoin qu'on
peut avoir de legé des gens qui arrêtent
et beaucoup de choses qui étaient en
route qui était complètement
disproportionnée pour justement garder
une vie équilibrée et agréable à vivre
en face d'elle de liste de droite celle
menée par thierry gastaud actuel
directeur de cabinet du maire de moore
pas ancien directeur de cabinet d'alexis
byette
je me suis engagé parce que j'aime
voisin j'aime ma vive depuis toujours
fait 20 ans que je la sers avec
engouement
et lorsque alexis bouillet tas a pris sa
décision de ne pas se représenter
les mômes son équipe m'ont demandé de
mener cette liste que j'ai accepté assez
rapidement
il veut continuer à nous accompagner
tout en laissant une nouvelle génération
s'installe et donc il est 19e pour faire
taire tout risque de réinstallation dans
un troisième tour commandes de la ville
nos priorités ça a été dans ces
circonstances économiques un peu
particulière pour les villes qui souffre
d'un désengagement massif de l'état ça a
été de se recentrer sur les missions
principales d'une ville les voisins
s'est toujours consacré à l'enfance à la
famille aux scolaires
olivier fonds zone n'est pas un inconnu
pour les piscines mois du quartier de
champ fleuri
il en est le président du comité
syndical il était ancien colistier
d'alexis gator mars 2014
là il a choisi de prendre la tête de
liste l'année dernière en fait j'ai fait
un travail de terrain qui consistait à
comprendre pourquoi nous avions perdu
j'ai rencontré jean louis tison et son
équipe et j'ai voulu rassembler et ce
qui est le cas aujourd'hui je suis la
seule liste à droite et au centre a
rassemblé en fait tous les courants de
la droite à voisins une candidature de
terrain est vraiment pour porter les
valeurs en fait de la préservation du
cadre de vie qui sont pas des mots des
mots anodins dans notre ville c'est
vraiment quelque chose extrêmement
important auquel je tiens et je
défendrai dans cette campagne la
préservation du cadre de vie et aussi
d'identité même deux voisins au sein de
l'intercommunalité
liste de gauche celle de jean h
conseiller municipal d'opposition depuis
il se détache de ses querelles
politiciennes nous considérons que
voisin a besoin de renouveau d'un nouvel
élan et d'une vie municipale apaisé et
l'expérience que nous avons de 20 ans de
conseillers municipaux nous permet
d'apporter cet apaisement qui est
absolument nécessaire à tous les chinois
une ambition écologique d'un côté et
nous voulons faire de la remise en
écoquartier nous voulons que des
logements soit accessible qu'on puisse
accueillir des jeunes familles des
familles monoparentales et que nous
puissions aussi proposer des logements
tout un profil résidentiel aux gens qui
viennent en voisins
trois listes de droite une liste à
gauche du déjà vu à voisins le
bretonneux qui d'élection en élection ne
parvient pas à régler les dissensions à
droite ça veut dire que ce sont des
intérêts personnels qui domine alors que
nous nous voulons répondre à l'intérêt
général de tous les clichés noir et non
pas régler des problèmes personnels et
des querelles d'ego je regrette rien du
tout moi dans la mesure où moi mon
équipe est soudée et repartait le
collège c'est à eux d'avoir des regrets
c'est par mois
la liste en trop c'est pas la mienne moi
je rassemble autour de moi des gens de
tous les horizons je rassemble c'est pas
le cas de mon principal concurrent qui
est thierry gastou c'est un peu le
reflet de l'histoire du cygne noir
il ya toujours eu un peu de distance ion
à droite parce que voisin est très
ancrée à droite et ça a toujours nourri
un peu les appétits
au vu de la sociologie de la commune
difficile en effet de penser que la
ville puisse échapper une nouvelle fois
une liste de droite
mais qu'en sera-t-il du score de la
gauche un résultat qui peut décider du
nouveau visage du conseil communautaire
car si actuellement la majorité est à
droite de 25 voix sur 23
si un élu de la gauche et chinoise fait
son entrée à l'agglomération
le rapport de force sera équilibré à 24
élus pour chaque bord politique
une situation complexe mais temporaire
en janvier 2016 cinq nouvelles villes
devraient intégrer la casse qui elles
sont toutes à droite
réponse dans les urnes ce dimanche pour
le premier tour et je reçois ce soir
grégory gary astier maire ump de
maurepas bonsoir bonsoir ce mot on l'a
vu maurepas qui va rejoindre saint
quentin en yvelines blain bientôt un mot
tout de même sur le scrutin de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui doit forcément
vous intéresser puisque se présentent
notamment la vue thierry gastaud qui est
votre directeur de cabinet actuellement
il est face à alexandra rosetti et vous
étiez remplaçant sur la liste qui a été
menée au départemental par alexandra
rosetti et yves vandewalle liste qui l'a
emporté alors là on s'y perd un petit
peu entre au milieu de ce conflit on va
préciser qu'il ya aucune investiture qui
a été donnée ni pour lui ni pour l'ump
mais aujourd'hui au sein de la droite et
du centre c'est ça crée une situation un
petit peu inconfortable écoutez moi je
suis maire de maurepas donc je
n'interviens pas dans les affaires de
voisins-le-bretonneux et j'aurais
tendance à dire que le meilleur gagne
mais lorsque votre directeur de cabinet
part au combat contre alexandra rosetti
alors que vous étiez sans remplaçant sur
la liste ça ne vous pose pas de souci
questo était vice ynwa à l'origine donc
c'est pas une nouveauté j'ai fait
campagne en effet qu'alexandra rosetti
c'est une femme compétente et qui mérite
d'être élu donc c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure je n'interviens
pas dans les affaires de
voisins-le-bretonneux juste un mot par
rapport à toutes ses divisions et
ensuite on parlera du sujet principal
pour lequel vous êtes là ce soir c'est
la fermeture de cette piscine ou de
maurepas du centre nautique
on parle de cette division une réaction
peut être aussi ça c'est au niveau
national de la déclaration de nicolas
sarkozy de ce matin qui a été a démenti
depuis à propos de françois bayrou
le président de l'ump qui aurait déclaré
bayrou c'est comme le sida quiconque le
touch moeurs des propos donc rapporté
par le parisien est démentie depuis par
nicolas sarkozy on le sent avec le
centre avec le modem s'est dit
difficile de trouver un consensus et que
tout le monde s'entende alors qu'on sort
des départementales et que le centre et
la droite ont affiché un visage uni le
sentait la droite ont été unis aux
dernières départemental les résultats
sont là après pour ce qui est des propos
nicolas sarkozy je crois qu'il est
revenu clairement dessus et qu' il ne
porte pas la responsabilité de ses
propos et je le crois
vous êtes venus ce soir nous parler
principalement de cette piscine ce
centre nautique ouvert voici 40 ans
aujourd'hui fermée en urgence pour des
raisons de sécurité on va donner tout de
suite la parole au mort d'asia néo mort
pas dire que pense-t-il de cette
fermeture et vous réagirez juste après
cissé sécurité ça paraît utile oui dans
quels cas la fermeture paraît en effet
les justifier écoutez ces questions de
sécurité je crois que le choix sur moi
j'habite le mesnil on nous avait fait le
coup
on dirait ça me concerne pas mais
fermez les pour réparation les centres
nautiques pendant la période d'été si
notre pas très judicieux ok c'est
logique
cette visite je la connais depuis 30 ans
et elle n'a jamais changé toujours
pareil donc et puis a passé deux choses
pour les enfants donc moi ça ne me
dérange pas du tout parce que tu as
changé elle est plus j'habite maurepas
mais j'ai trouvé mieux ailleurs donc
c'est dommage c'est très très de mac
mais si ça avait été fait avant les
travaux il répond aussi à faire
maintenant
alors pourquoi cette fermeture vous avez
dit voilà si les travaux a été fait
avant bah oui écouter quand je suis
arrivé aux responsabilités que j'ai
changé directrice générale des services
en novembre dernier j'ai découvert
l'existence d'un audit sur l'état
général de ces structures là qui date
d'octobre 2009 et qui annonçait déjà
plus de 700 millions euros de travaux
sur quatre ans
ces travaux n'ont pas été fait je pose
des questions pourquoi et qui savez je
n'ai pas la réponse en cours aujourd'hui
et de ce fait d'une enquête en interne
justement pour savoir s'il ya des
responsabilités qui n'ont pas été
assumée prise par l'ancienne équipe pour
être très clair par l'ancien parti oui
j'ai mené ma petite enquête de
évidemment la responsabilité elle est
toujours sur les épaules des élus donc
je me pose des questions et quand j'ai
découvert cet audit j'ai demandé tout de
suite auprès du même bureau d'experts
bureau veritas une enquête
complémentaire
un audit complémentaire dont j'ai eu les
résultats vendredi dernier définitif et
c'est pour ça au vu de ces résultats qui
sont catastrophiques j'ai décidé de
protéger la sécurité du public et donc
de fermer provisoirement l'établissement
pendant un mois
en attendant un autre dit d'un autre
cabinet d'experts aujourd'hui la
situation ce centre nautique il faut
tout refaire dedans qu'est-ce qu'il faut
refaire rien n'a été fait depuis son
ouverture aucun entretien aucun entrave
alors s'il y avait eu l'entretien
courant et là je remercie bien sûr
l'ensemble des agents communaux qui ont
fait remarquablement leur travail
après il ya eu un gros déficit
d'investissement les 700000 euros qui
était prévu pour la rénover pour la
faire fonctionner correctement n'ont pas
été fait déjà en 2009 et en 2009 elle
aurait déjà dû fermer parce que la
sécurité du public étaient déjà menacés
il y a eu à deux reprises la chute
d'éléments du faux plafond et notamment
il ya un peu plus d'un an au dessus
du bassin où les bébés nageurs exerçait
sa a été retenu par les filets ont été
installés donc ce n'est pas rien comme
sujet donc moi j'ai pris mes
responsabilités et la vue de cet audit
évidemment j'ai pris la décision qui
s'imposait là il ya un deuxième audit
que vous avez commandé pour établir un
petit peu les travaux qui seraient
nécessaires on imagine mal la piscine
rouvrir au mois de mai
là vous avez pris une suspension
l'ouverture j'ai pris évidemment une
mesure provisoire mais il faut pas se le
cacher l'avenir est sombre pour cette
structure
d'autant plus qu' il y a une relation
affective avec la piscine à maurepas
j ai moi même appris à nager j'ai grandi
et maurepas et donc évidemment c'est
dans la douleur que j'ai annoncé sa mort
passe bien mais je garantis leur
sécurité est évidemment une fois que
l'audit sera rendue tous les scénarios
sont envisageables
mais je le dis et je le redis je
souhaite une piscine à maurepas
il ya des fonds aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être débloqués par la ville déjà pour
faire des travaux en fonction de ce que
dira le deuxième audit
alors il ya des fonds oui et non tout va
dépendre des sa santé sa main portant
oui complètement
d'autant plus que là on est plus à
700000 euros mais si c'est les travaux
seulement sur la couverture et le faux
plafond on est à plus de 2 millions
d'euros 2 millions d'euros ce n'est pas
rien dans la situation financière
actuelle
après il faudra a mandaté un cabinet
d'experts qui pourra nous dire s'il faut
réhabiliter totalement cette structure
ou détruire et reconstruire et là c'est
une autre affaire effectivement ça
serait peut-être la solution la plus
simple est ce qu'il va mener ma question
suivante aujourd'hui maurepas est la
seule commune à gérer cette piscine
alors maurepas et la sociale pour le
financement serait commune à gérer cette
piscine nous avons quarante mille
scolaires par an dont dix neuf mille de
maurepas 13002 il encourt six mille de
coignières donc à la base c'est déjà une
piscine intercommunale mais c'est comme
da ne participe pas à l'opération
entièrement absolument si elle participe
financièrement
donc c'est pour ça que si nous nous
lançons dans un nouveau projet
l'intercommunalité avec la comédie
d'agglomération de saint quentin aura
tout son sens justement 1er janvier 2016
maurepas va rejoindre saint quentin en
yvelines là c'est clairement un message
que vous envoyez à l'agglomération de
saint quentin
la piscine est fermée j'arrive au mois
de janvier il va falloir débarqué de
l'argent à la force des choses
évidemment mais j'aurais souhaité que
cela se passe autrement
mais là je le dis j'ai pris une mesure
d'urgence je garantis la sécurité du
public parce que c'est pas négociable
après on envisagera tous les scénarios
possibles mais je le dis je souhaite une
piscine à maurepas et nous verrons avec
les partenaires possibles ce qu'il est
possible de faire voilà quand vous
parlez des partenaires ou pas on pense
forcément à l'agglomération de saint
quentin michel laugier ed principalement
à la région mais vous avez discuté avec
michel laugier président de l'interco de
saint quentin en yvelines avec jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous et j'ai eu des
échanges que ce que je faisais tenu tout
de suite au courant de la situation avec
le maire de coignières j'ai également
appelé les présidents d'associations
concernées les scolaires pas aussi
l'inspecteur académique
donc voilà tous les partenaires ont été
contactées et j'ai eu des réunions avec
eux aujourd'hui encore est cette semaine
pour le président de la codah communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin il est
au courant naturellement et sa réponse
est attendons l'audit et pourquoi pas 50
ans pourrait financer une piscine
l'année pour le monde on n'est pas là
mais en tout cas ce sera un élément de
négociation si toutefois on devait en
arriver là mais je vous fais pas de
dessin je pense qu'on en arrivera là
puisque l'état des structures de toute
façon à plus de 40 ans et l'audit est
très claire on a des gros problèmes sur
la couverture le bâtiment prend l'eau et
on n'a même pas fait d'audit sur la
situation hydraulique en dessous les
bassins qui s'affaisse également donc à
deux scénarios possibles ans et soit la
piscine va simplement fermé et va
disparaître il n'y aura pas d'autres
piscines soit il y aura une nouvelle
piscine elle sera intercommunale je
retiens la cinquante solutions il y aura
une piscine dans tous les cas qu'elle
soit réhabilité ou une nouvelle mais il
faudra des sous pour sa médiocrité
valoir il y aura une piscine est mort
pas de toute façon sur le sur le plan
pratique aujourd'hui parce que c'est
fermé et vous l'avez dit il faut pas
s'imaginer une réouverture prochaine
dans les semaines à venir vu les
questions de sécurité qui se posent
comment ça se passe pour les associatifs
comment ça se passe pour les écoles
aussi qui utilisent le centre nautique
qui utilisait jusqu'à présent centre
nautique alors c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce que là cette initiation
d'urgence donc évidemment on commence à
faire je commence à faire travailler les
services pour envisager des solutions
c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui j'ai reçu
l'ensemble du personnel éducatif où on
va tenter de trouver des créneaux
disponibles dans les piscines des villes
aux alentours
donc je vais appeler mes collègues
maires pour voir ce qu'il est possible
de faire ça pour être à
montigny-le-bretonneux absolument ça
pourrait être
les essarts le roi c'est pour être le
mil saint-denis chevreuse par exemple
nous verrons et la priorité également
c'est de trouver des créneaux aux clubs
qui ont des compétitions et là c'est la
priorité donc de leur trouver des
créneaux pour qu'ils puissent exercer
correctement sans pénaliser leurs leur
club est-ce qu'il ya les scolaires mais
les associatifs aussi qui font payer
leurs adhérents par exemple les
adhérents telles celles qui vont
forcément qu'il faut régler tout toutes
ces choses là qui sont qui se compliquer
pour les associations gellért ce soir à
19h d'ailleurs pour en parler et
envisager toutes les solutions possibles
pour moi les pénaliser mais c'est vrai
que autant que les associations que les
scolaires mais c'est aussi les
mortuaciens ses 170 mille entrées par an
quarante mille scolaires
donc c'est vraiment une piscine à
vocation intercommunale est donc
maintenant il faut réfléchir et faire
les choses ensemble sur l'avenir il ya
un consensus pour terminer autour de ce
sujet là au sein de votre conseil
municipal avec l'opposition serait oui
c'était j'ai reçu les élus de
l'opposition vendredi soir pour les
avertir de la décision que j'avais prise
avec mon équipe
bon évidemment il découvrait également
l'audit surprenant alors qu'ils ont été
aux responsabilités pendant 25 ans ce
site en attendant tre pour pour certains
d'entre eux ceci étant dit voilà
maintenant on avance tous dans la même
direction il ya des gros problèmes de
sécurité
ils sont d'accord avec cela donc voilà
maintenant on acte et puis on avance
pour construire l'avenir
merci grégory galeristes et maire de
maurepas le centre nautique est donc
fermé provisoirement mais cela devrait
se prolonger au delà du mois de mai
merci à vous politique toujours et cette
tribune du maire de versailles dans les
colonnes du figaro aujourd'hui le député
maire de versailles divers droite qui
fustige la politique du gouvernement
réforme territoriale sujets de société
il pose cette question les socialistes
aurait-il recours à la politique de la
terre brûlée après moi le déluge
c'est aussi à dire sur le site internet
du quotidien culture à présent viviane
mère son nom ne vous dit peut-être pas
grand chose elle est photographe franco
américaine et si son travail n'a pas été
reconnu de son vivant elle apparaît
aujourd'hui comme une artiste à part
entière dans son style de portraits de
rue une exposition lui est consacrée à
versailles en ce moment le récit de
mathilde capbern sur les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
des visages inconnus la france des
années 50 vu par l'objectif de vivienne
meyer une photographe décédé dans
l'anonymat en 2009 et qui apparaît
désormais comme l'une des plus
brillantes photographe de rue né à new
york d'une mère française l'artiste
séjourne à plusieurs reprises dans les
hautes-alpes
au début des années 50 elle y réalise un
important travail photographique avec
mon modèle il a le temps c'est proche de
la rue proche de la réalité
une sensibilité c'est ça qui nous touche
en fait c'est que havas au plus près
d'eux des gens qui sont là autour de
nous est en effet les coen faire
graviter moi en tant que le progrès
photo c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
comprend que c'est pas parce qu'on fait
un instantané
photo pas composer dans le lot avait des
gens qui par ce n'est que c'est
extrêmement composé au delà des
portraits d'anonymes qui vient de maeyer
aime aussi se prendre en photo
certains experts pensent que c'est une
façon de se voir à travers son
esthétisme photographique
d'autres voient cela comme un exercice
de style ces autoportraits sont
tellement précis c'était plus pour
régler son appareil faire des cadrages
faire des plans de l'été sur elle même
sur l'arrière plan moi je pense que
c'était c'est vraiment un travail de
photographe qu'elle a fait avec son
appareil la galerie de l'école des
beaux-arts a pour volonté de mettre en
lumière les photographes inconnue c'est
l'humanisme de deux de ses photographies
umanis d'autant plus précieux quand on
connaît le photographe est cantonné
quand on connaît l'artiste qui était
quelqu'un de particulier de spécial
et qu'il y à un moment quand alcool et
son oeil à l'appareil photo devenue
quelqu'un d'autre et ça ça rend la
photographie et les photos graphiques
nous présente encore plus précieuse
intéressante
viviane mayer réalise plus de 120000
photographie entre 1950 et la fin des
années 80 son exposition est proposée
jusqu'au 23 avril à versailles
du sport pour conclure cette édition les
championnats départementaux de pony
games ont été organisées ce dimanche sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines une vingtaine des équipes des
yvelinois ont participé à cette
compétition équestre le reportage est
signée michael et demi d'euros elodie
moines de l'équitation comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu les championnats
départementaux de pony games était
programmé ce dimanche sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
une vingtaine d'équipés yvelinoise
composé de cinq cavaliers à participer à
ce rendez vous la compétition mêle à la
fois le sport équestre et des jeux alors
le pony games est une pratique qui est
né au royaume uni donc qui consiste à
utiliser les premiers objets qui passe
sous la main pour pouvoir pratiquer une
équitation ludique avec son cheval donc
ça s'est développé actuellement ça se
traduit par la présence de jeu comme des
déplacements de tasse sur les piquets
des déplacements de balles sur les cônes
ou encore des déplacements de drapés
dans des coins des jeux par exemple en
équipe comme passer des portes entre des
piquets de cavaliers ça bouge sans voix
on n'est pas un échange de dusseau
dresse basique à l'esprit d'équipé que
chance génial cette discipline compte
près de 200 licenciés dans les yvelines
la section classés en plusieurs
catégories
il ya trois catégories en fait c'est la
série de la série une élite est en fait
qu en jouant serré nogent série une donc
laisser les joueurs un peu plus les gens
un peu plus difficile que la série 2 et
il ya des jeux d'atf à rabat est
d'ailleurs en fait on court à côté du
cheval et on remonte à côté on remonte
en fait encore en ligne au galop du côté
des résultats le club hippique de ville
vers deux jours josas est illustrée dans
la carrière de saint quentin en yvelines
l'équipe a remporté les championnats
départementaux et s'est qualifié par la
même occasion pour les championnats de
france des pony games
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal rendez
vous demain aux mêmes horaires tout de
suite et comme chaque mercredi un
nouveau numéro de kiosques votre
hebdomadaire dédié à la culture très
bonne soirée